I was checking out the david pakman show
subreddit this morning at david
pakman.com slash reddit some really
interesting discussions that i want to
just show you here of course i hope that
you will subscribe and jump into some of
these discussions closing in on 2,400 of
our viewers and listeners there we've
got a team of moderators it's all
happening I know Pat's on or reddit
every day every day we're done
interesting all right let's look at some
interesting stories from the last day or
so on the David Pakman show reddit one
interesting discussion how far is the
United States from fascism and this led
to a very interesting and detailed
discussion I encourage you to read
through and include your thoughts there
also from the david pakman show reddit
is the two-state solution a lost cause
when it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict a rare thoughtful contribution
in terms of commentary on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in the
midst of mostly unproductive
bomb-throwing when it comes to that good
discussion happening on reddit as well
also does Trump really not see Giuliani
in front of his face and this recent
footage this is funny there's a video of
Trump speaking at a table and Rudy
Giuliani is literally two feet away
directly across from Trump and Trump is
talking about him like he's not there
and then seemed surprised when Giuliani
just starts talking right in front of
them I give Trump a pass on this one
because sometimes I'll be looking for my
phone and then I noticed it's in my hand
the whole time ok well fair enough I I
don't know that that's exactly how I
would judge this situation but at least
at the analysis that pat is applying to
it ok also from a reddit discussion
forum what's funny about orange
president sort of a discussion about
whether it is or isn't funny when I
refer to trump is our first orange
president diverging opinions on that
important issue online also from the
reddit discussion forum they call him
David you cannot write this stuff Pakman
yeah there's been I I felt compelled pat
to use that term because so much of
what's going on in the Trump
administration if it was part of a house
of cards episode script you would say we
can't use this because no one would ever
believe it and it's actually happening
during the Trump administration and I
find myself compelled to say you cannot
write this stuff
just like the idea of putting a quote in
between your first and last name they're
kind of like a new nickname a new
nickname or middleman yet and lastly
from the reddit discussion forum rare
shot of David Pakman adjusting his
thermostat this relates to a story I
told yesterday on the bonus show about
problems I'm having with the heat and my
house making very strange noises and
somebody posted a picture of what looks
like either an aircraft technician or
someone defusing a bomb of sorts wearing
a some kind of best and suggesting that
that's what it's like when I adjust my
thermostat at home very funny very
subtle I like it check out all of these
discussions and start your own on our
reddit at david pakman.com slash re d di
t